camilla n'avait pas prévu passé les
premiers jours ensoleillés du printemps
avec une arme à la main mais cette
vendeuse de fromage et jambon dans un
supermarché se dit rassuré de pouvoir
consacrer le prochain mois à parfaire le
maniement des armes
c'est important dit elle parce que je
veux faire quelque chose au lieu de
rester à la maison et m'inquiéter de ne
pas savoir quoi faire ou ce qui va se
passer
ce qui l'inquiète c'est la russie
camilla fait partie des réservistes de
la défense territoriale de la suède en
temps normal elle doit consacrer
quelques jours par année à
l'entraînement mais ça ne suffit plus à
décider son pays
c'est tout près de chez nous alors c'est
devenu une réalité dit jeannette c'est
inquiétant mais je n'ai pas peur
je n'ai aussi est volontaire et ne vient
pas seul ses deux chiennes entraînés à
la détection de drogues d'explosifs
pourrait aussi se porter à la défense de
la suède
shawn poutine a clairement montré au
monde qu'il est prête à utiliser la
force militaire pour atteindre ses
objectifs politiques comme gatland a une
grande importance stratégique bien sûr
qu'il faut se préparer
mcnish riqueval commande les forces du
régiment de gotland au temps de la
guerre froide la suède avait déployé
jusqu'à 25000 de ses soldats sur l'île
quand elle a pris fin gotland a été
complètement démilitarisé
souilem ans nos pions la suède n'est pas
le seul pays d'europe qui est changer
d'appproche et qu'ils se soient
détournées de la défense nationale pour
participer à des opérations militaires
internationales fait valoir le
commandant mais dans la situation
actuelle que nous vivons c'était une
erreur
ce que le commandant qualifient d'erreur
a été rectifié en 2014 après l'annexion
de la crimée par la russie aujourd'hui
200 soldats de l'armée régulière sont en
poste à gotland ils seront bientôt
beaucoup plus nombreux le gouvernement
suédois vient d'annoncer avoir mis de
côté 163 millions d'euros
supplémentaires soit plus de 220
millions de dollars pour renforcer ses
infrastructures militaires survivre
si gotland en plein coeur de la mer
baltique reçoit aujourd'hui autant
d'attention c'est qu'elle est située à
quelques 300 kilomètres de l'enclavé
russe de kaliningrad et c'est de là que
la russie pourrait bien mettre à
exécution ses menaces de riposte
si la suède décidé de se joindre à
l'otan au delà des côtes du gotland il
est là le débat qui émergent à la
surface pour la suède aujourd'hui tout
comme la finlande voisine le pays
scandinave a fait de la non adhésion à
l'otan une véritable doctrine pendant
des décennies et le gouvernement social
démocrate serait sur le point de rompre
avec cette tradition de neutralité
militaire l'opinion publique suédoise
aussi à basculer de façon importante
depuis l'invasion russe en ukraine un
suédois sur deux se dit aujourd'hui en
faveur du jamais vu
fracture d'abord nous avons vu que
l'ukraine n'était pas protégée par le
temps nous avons compris que nous ne
saurions sans doute pas non plus
pourquoi nous avons aussi vu que la
menace était réelle souk des paroles et
mais ensuite nous avons vu les
provocations et les menaces de la russie
depuis longtemps il est allé trop loin
alors nous n'avons pas primer nous
sommes fâchés explique-t-il
une colère que partagent cette députée
suédoise au parlement européen il ya un
mois elle foulait le sol de boudhha en
banlieue de kiev elle en est revenue
hanter par les crimes de guerre qui ont
été commis
swissinfo ch que nous avons vu abuja dit
elle la même chose est en train de se
reproduire ailleurs en ukraine pendant
que nous sommes ici c'est très
douloureux
il ya là de damoclès il est venu dire à
ce petit groupe de citoyens suédois est
réfugié ukrainien rassemblés au centre
de stockholm par un samedi pluvieux car
on n'avait cependant pas besoin de voir
les horreurs de la guerre en ukraine
pour soutenir l'adhésion de son pays à
l'otan le parti libéral dont elle est
membre milite depuis longtemps en faveur
de l'alliance militaire
est maintenant c'est urgent dit elle ce
qui s'est passé en ukraine a réveillé la
société suédoise au dessous il se sent a
été
tous ont visiblement comme elle
bouleversé par le sort de l'ukraine ils
ne partagent pas nécessairement son
enthousiasme pour l'otan un peu à
l'image des propos des dirigeants
suédois gillian paraît plus résiniques
emballé à l'idée d'abandonner la
neutralité de la suède il le faut dit
elle mais c'est le sacrifice d'un idéal
mallet
il y a tant d'aspects que je n'aime pas
mais j'ai peur pour la finlande aussi et
je ne vais pas l'abandonner si elle
rejoint l'otan
[Musique]
le choix est douloureux pour beaucoup
mais il semble aujourd'hui qu'il sera
sans surprise la suède doit annoncer sa
décision dimanche prochain